you wish that our places had been
exchanged that i had died instead of
lenny
yes i wish that
okay so another mind-blowing episode of
the boys has just dropped and as always
we're here to break down the entire
entry from start to finish
i just want to get straight into it but
if you haven't had a chance to check out
the latest episode yet then i highly
recommend that you check out now
as there's going to be spoilers here for
both the show and comics
make sure you smash the thumbs up button
if you've been enjoying the coverage so
far
and please subscribe to the channel so
you don't miss our breakdown of the
finale
with all that out of the way as always
this is the heavy spoilers show i'm your
host paul
now let's get into the video okay so
episode 7
opens in the room of a die hard
stormfront fan
known in the show as a storm chaser the
poster of her that's adorned above his
bed
is actually extremely similar to one of
the most popular images of the show's
comic book counterpart
and after learning of her true history
last week it's nice that we start to see
how these line up
there's also an image of a soldier boy
poster and though we don't actually
catch the full face of the character
just yet
the statue of him does appear later in
the episode
now throughout this intro we witness how
the constant piling on of one message
can heavily influence people and it's
clearly a comment on extremists being
swayed by either political figures or
celebrities
this character played by charlie koontz
is surrounded by the constant idea that
immigrants are dangerous
due to the super terrorist threat after
witnessing a headlight reflection in a
shopkeeper's eyes
he slowly becomes paranoid and then
kills him
immigration is often a hot talking point
in elections
and the media often portray this
demographic in a negative light
similar to what we see in the show we
can clearly see how someone can be
caught up in all of this
and we watch as charlie ends up pointing
the finger at someone he shouldn't
because of the lies he's been told
what's interesting is
because of what stormfront has been
publicly saying charlie
likely believes that he's a hero much
like she is
when in fact he's just a murderer and in
the episode
the villain even talks down this act
while still promoting her agenda
other notable elements in this scene are
the appearance of dan duran
who provides the voice over on the radio
duran has appeared as a news anchor in
numerous things from dawn of the dead to
x-men and more
dan is actually listed as a vnn news
correspondent
which likely stands for vault news
network cementing
how far the propaganda from the
higher-ups is fed to society
occur to victoria newman and lamplighter
practicing his testimony for the
congress hearing at the end of the
episode
we get far more of a focus on newman in
this entry and the character is of
course based on
aoc a real world new york congress
representative
last time we saw her homelander remarked
on her dancing video which went viral
and this is similar to the real world
figure who picked up a lot of publicity
for doing the same thing
newman is actually based on the comic
book character victor newman
aka vic the veep a complete idiot in the
source material
who actually ends up as the president of
the united states
but whether they go that route or not
remains to be seen
now vic says that lamplight's testimony
won't be enough
and thus billy heads out to get someone
even better
bumping into his father along the way
now i think thematically that this
episode is very much about fathers
and the relationships that they have
with their children we see that billy's
dad used to brutally beat both him
and his brother which led to the latter
ending his own life
in his mind his father carried these
beatings out as a kindness
that would better prepare the two for
the real world but we see how that
turned out
mirroring this homelander pulls back the
curtain on the quote-unquote real world
for ryan
and shows him that he's been living a
lie like butch's dad
he believes that this is a kindness
however he's likely just opened the door
for the corporation to get its claws
into him
which will mean he's brought up as a
commodity instead of the child that
becca was treating him as
lamplighter also discusses how he burnt
down his home when he was a child
and instead of scolding him for it his
dad celebrated that his son was a soup
this would of course send him off on the
path that would eventually lead to him
setting himself a light in front of the
seven statue
reflecting this huey says that after his
mother left
his father sunk into a deep depression
and he thought that this would inspire
him to do something great
even though it hasn't well well i think
it has but
he doesn't seem it like that way look
anyway frenchy mentions his father
losing his mind which pushed him towards
his mother
and mallory discusses with mother's milk
how he likely
won't be able to avenge his father's
death and should instead try and build a
relationship with his daughters
which ultimately he doesn't do at least
for now anyway now
on top of this we also see a betrayal by
vogelbaum
who in many ways was a surrogate father
to homelander
he states he wanted to make him the
strongest man in the world but that
homelander didn't even want to fill that
role
this is of course similar to billy's
childhood who too was toughened up by
his dad
and in the end i really appreciate how
the kind of drawing parallels between
the characters
in the end vogelbaum somewhat betrays
his son
and decides to testify at congress in
order to unveil
all the dirty secrets that the
corporation has this ultimately doesn't
work out for him
but throughout the entry we have this
idea of the sons inheriting the sins of
their father
it's not just dads that are bad either
and we see how useless annie's mother is
too
when she stupidly informs ford
beforehand that they plan to take a
break from the corporation
since she removed her tracking device
last week they've been looking for her
and black noir arrives and easily takes
her down
she's pretty much being used as a patsy
right now and i have a theory that
stormfront was looking to take her off
the board early
because she's pretty much the polar
opposite to her power-wise
annie's abilities involved draining the
electricity from an object to power her
and with stormfront's abilities being
based around this
it's likely that she would pretty
cleanly whip her arse in a fight
speaking of asses there's some hilarious
hub moments throughout the episode
and we sit with huey and lamplia as as
they watch some
let's call them parodies now there's
several key appearances by the seven in
these
however the most notable one i think is
the film featuring a riff on jack from
jupiter
in the comics jack was an original
member of the seven
that was basically martian manhunter for
the group
actually have a feeling that he will be
popping up down the line but to see him
here
is quite hilarious they go through the
collection and there's also another
starlight
holding a train which is a reference to
the comics in which he was forced to
blow him
homelander and black noir in order to be
allowed into the seven
i'm telling you them comics are very
very dark
there's also one in which homelander
bangs someone's wife
which don't let billy say that please
in addition to this huey also wears a
journey t-shirt from their japan escape
tour in 1981
and don't stop believing that i won't be
buying this on amazon right now
not really an easter egg but i just like
that [ __ ] now annie is kept in a cell
block
that looks similar to the prison from
the movie cube these blocks were
completely secure
and she's unable to escape from it until
lamplighter and huey
mount a rescue mission to save her
across town homeland homelander and
stormfront hold a rally
and i love how homelander says who's the
real heroes
huh you are i don't know i every time he
says that it just cracks me up
they send thoughts and prayers to the
convenience store owner at the start of
the episode
who we learn is actually called kul deep
singh
now this was on the name badge but it is
possible that the character's name
has also been chosen for a specific
reason koldeep singh singhal was a
member of a political party in
india and he was recently convicted of
murder rape
and criminal conspiracy might be a reach
but
stormbrunt announcing it like this would
would make stupid youtubers google a
name
and then see the connection so that they
would make logic leaps about what her
agenda really is
wake up people i'm i'm sending thought
and prayers though
now i think this rally is very much
laced with trump-esque dialogue
and whatever your political standing is
there are a lot of similarities here
the pair discuss how they're the most
persecuted people on the planet
which is something that is often used to
criticize negative media publications
surrounding him
they also mention how the country used
to be better which
could be riffing on make america great
again i'm trying to avoid politics right
now as
it's all just kind of a touchy subject
but let me know whether you
agree or disagree on if that's the
message that the writers were trying to
convey
now we discover that stormfront is
keeping annie alive
and homelander keeps saying that this is
a mistake
personally i think that stormfront is
doing this so that the ending scene
could potentially be pinned on her
as i really can't think of any other
reason to have her around
stormfront does state that a common
enemy rallies the base
and thus they may have kept her confined
to blame her for the attack
stormfront also looks at a baby and gets
very broody
saying that her daughter looked exactly
the same
last week we did theorize that she was
gonna try and have a kid with homelander
but i think that the show is just gonna
skip over this and go a much shorter
route
and just have her become a somewhat
adoptive mother to ryan
she's clearly teasing wanting a child
and due to her connections involved
was likely well aware that homelander
had one when they arrive she tells ryan
that he's very very special
because he's the first natural born
superhero and as we know from her work
last week
she's trying to find a way to refine
compound b to mass produce supes
it may even be possible that the key to
this lies in ryan's blood
and getting a hold of him is actually
her end game
we know that v being used on adults is
very hit and miss
but perhaps something within his dna is
going to unlock the secrets of this
and that ryan has been basically her
plan this whole time
homelander even agrees at one point that
keeping him sheltered and raising him
away from the world is the right thing
to do
but stormfront likely sinks their claws
in and she is the reason why he alters
the deal
later in the entry elsewhere maeve's
relationship falls apart
with the revelation last week making it
so that elena can't live with her
anymore
i loved how she ended up sleeping with a
guy and ashley was horrified because
she'd been marketing her as a lesbian
even though from the start she said that
she was bisexual
corporations only really care about
inclusivity when they can market it
and i think maeve is a prime example of
that her being with a man just
complicates things
and thus ashley is furious i really
think that maeve is living on borrowed
time right now
and after what she does later in the
episode it seems like she's not going to
be in the seven much longer
i guess relationships can be tough but
it isn't
all doom and gloom and french and kimako
have a real heart to heart
the deep also introduces his wife to a
train and it all seems like it's it's
gonna be fine
until alistair adona steps in now adona
mentions that he has a meeting with
edgar to get the pair back into the
seven
and it's starting to seem like there's
some big master plan to keep certain
people off the board
for specific moments we see that
shockwave
aka a trains replacement gets killed at
the end of the episode
and this is likely carried out by cindy
who as we know has been working for
stormfront from time to time
so with him out the way it does seem
like a train will be back in the 7 soon
but i have to wonder whether this was
all planned out and that's how alistair
was able to get him back in so quickly
adona also says that no one from the
church is to associate with eagle the
archer
i thought it was hilarious how the deep
said that he was the most kind and
caring person ever
until adonis said he was toxic and he
was just like yep
no now you mention it he he was he was a
bit toxic
now eagles saw the failure in the
program and the scientology-esque
organization booted him out
because he wouldn't cut off contact with
his mother i guess the fresca
brainwashing didn't work
and they then leaked personal
information about him obviously
this kind of hints at what the church
will do to the deep and a train if they
decide to leave
and it's going to be interesting to see
what happens when they say
no now when hughie and lamplighter get
to vote tower
the latter does something completely
left field that i wasn't expecting at
all i think this is actually a reference
to the burning monk
a real life figure that set himself on
fire in protest to the persecution of
buddhists
my jaw was on the floor when this
happened and actually does leave the
door open for the show to line up with
the comics
when we first meet lamplighter in the
source material the character is in a
zombie-like state
having died at the hands of colonel
mallory the compound v in his system
actually boots up his brain and thus he
comes back to life
but he's a complete mess the deaths no
different
could even lead to him coming back to
life i think it's going to be
interesting to see if he returns
to be fair he was pretty armless hey
you're having that
now it's at this time that black noir
busts annie up and this reminded me a
lot of the terminator or mr x from
resident evil
maeve actually comes in and saves her
and the show further takes a dump on
almond joy
by having her stuff on in his mouth to
set off his nut allergy
this is a reference to episode 4 when it
was mentioned as being serial killer
john wayne gacy's favorite chocolate bar
huey said that beside him and he was the
only person who liked them
i do like how the show is kind of tied
together that her favorite thing
is also black noise weakness now we do
see under his mask for a split second
as may pulls it up now from this we can
confirm that that is indeed nathan
mitchell under his mask
but he also has a zombie-like texture to
his skin
to me this signifies that the show is
indeed moving away from the source
material
and going in its own direction with the
character now if you don't want the
comics or potentially show runed
and skip forward 30 seconds as we will
be spoiling some certain things
if you're still here then thanks for
sticking around and in the comics it's
revealed that noir is actually a clone
of homelander that's a contingency plan
in case he goes rogue
the fact that this is an
african-american actor whose face we
actually see
cements that they are indeed moving away
from this and all the theories that he
is in fact a clone of edgar
are starting to become more and more
likely edgar is of course not afraid of
homelander
and he has an almost master like hold
over noir so it does make sense that the
one person he would be able to trust
would in fact be himself let me know
your best theories below on this
but for the moment i think it is safe to
say that they're now moving completely
away from the comics
what is in line with the comics though
is that maeve stays behind
and it will be interesting to see if she
finally has a showdown with homelander
like she does in the source material she
really was brave maeve
in the end now huey grabs lamplighter's
hand
saves annie's mother and reunites with
her to escape the building
elsewhere homelander and stormfront take
ryan and billy meets with his mother
in the same cafe that annie did hers i
love this symmetry in these two moments
and we kind of see how two mothers tried
to do the right thing
but instead ended up doing the wrong one
i guess all parents in the boys universe
suck
but at least the two get this moment
together before we head into the final
mind-blowing scene crap i did that joke
already didn't i
now i got a lot of batman v superman
vibes from this finale
there being a testimonial hearing that
pretty much gets shut down
what exactly is going on well
as mentioned earlier i do think that
cindy is behind this
and that she has finally arrived to take
revenge we did see her hitchhiking last
week
and exploding heads is indeed part of
her power set
but who's controlling her and is it
actually bought
well as mentioned earlier they were
rearing the deep and a train to return
this was a public hearing that would
make their company seem bad
and thus it does make sense that they
would want to sabotage it
their heroes such as stormfront and
homelander are still safe by the end of
it
and it does make sense that stormfront
would build a fail-safe into cindy
so that she could control her cindy
could have exploded stormfront's head at
any time when she set her luce on rainer
so i do believe that she does hold some
kind of power over her
this attack will of course further her
agenda about the super terrorist threat
and doing it in such a public manner
makes me believe that she's
actually the one behind it all obviously
we won't know until
next friday which is a shame but it does
look like billy is furious that another
chance that he had to take down vort
has been cast to the side it is however
at the end of the season next week
so it would be amazing if they headed
out to the hearing to try and take them
down during this
but i guess we're just gonna have to see
there's a lot of potential avenues
but that closes out the episode and as
always i'd love to hear your thoughts on
it so comment below and let me know
if you enjoyed this video then please
drop a thumbs up and make sure you check
out our other breakdowns on the series
which are going to be linked at the end
you want to support the channel and get
to see content early then please
consider clicking the join button below
you can also come chat with us on the
discord server linked in the description
or heavy spoilers on twitter thanks for
making until the end of the video
you being the best i've been paul and
i'll see you next time take care
peace
[Music]
you